[Music]
hello uh my name is jhan marku and today
i'm going to be sharing my presentation
entitled debunking myths and
misconceptions of the psychedelic
industry
the most important thing you may learn
today is on this slide and that is my
email address so feel free to write me
jaehan at
marku-aurora.com if you'd like any of
the references or further information
so who am i and what am i doing here
two very important questions to always
ask before beginning
anything involving psychedelics
so
uh i received my phd for studying
molecular pharmacology and cell biology
of drugs and their interactions at
receptors largely focused on
cannabinoids things like thc and other
drugs of abuse i am also a published
basic and clinical researcher
i have received
training in sulfiden assisted therapy
and i'm also the internet in chief of a
research journal
and i'm going to be sharing with you
today an article that i published in
rolling stone
about psychedelics
i'm going to start off with some
information that's not in that article
about the pharmacological history so
we'll discuss
a little bit about the early discoveries
where we are now with research centers
in research and then i'm going to go on
to a little bit of clarifications or
myth busing
we'll talk about how psychedelics are
much more than lsd or mushrooms and i
really want your imagination to
percolate on this
are there other psychedelic or hosogenic
products outside of fungi and
synthesized lab derivatives
i'm also going to talk about publicly
traded companies
and i think there is some confusion here
about what exactly these companies do
and i hope to clarify that i'm also
going to speak to gimmick ventures and
the havoc they're wrecking you know
wrecking on environments and people's
health
and then clearly distinguishing
some of these so-called health retreats
from true clinical and therapy practices
and i'm also going to discuss
the last point is on about taking
psychedelics doesn't innately make you
better at something it doesn't make you
a better person doesn't make you a more
peaceful person
practice is the path to mastery so if
taking psychedelics will probably just
make you better at taking psychedelics
so so we'll discuss that
but the main takeaways a little
neatly
packaged products i hope you take away
from this
are one mainly uh that you now know what
the 5 ht2a receptor is
or does or what it's involved with or
something that it's related to
psychedelics in some way that would be a
great takeaway so this is the main
target for the effects of things like
psilocybin and lsd and if you don't know
what those are we'll discuss them in
detail shortly
psilocybin is perhaps
i consider many experts consider to be
the most well studied psychedelic
product in this area we know a lot more
about it you can
in the united states you can
go into a therapy
session for psychedelics and it will
most likely be a psilocybin purified
product
the sonoran desert toad uh you may have
heard of toad liquors in a crude way
what's interesting about this and we'll
discuss this when we get to gimmick
ventures is there's actually no
documented historical use and i know
what you're saying you're saying dr
markku people have worshipped toads for
centuries
not dmt toads
and so this is actually a gimmick that
has been conjured up over the last few
decades as an excuse to
sell
you know extracted dmt toads to people
and to decimate wildlife populations
again we'll discuss this aspect and i'll
share some examples
historical and modern examples of how
psychedelics
can affect people will also discuss
abuse and risks associated with them
and i think one of the main things i'd
like people to to remember is that
experiences on psychedelics especially
ego death or revisiting trauma
are not necessarily tranquil or peaceful
i think we have to think keep that in
mind while psychedelics do have
a great promise in therapy and they have
a low abuse potential
they are not necessarily peaceful
experiences for
people who are not accustomed to them
however one interesting thing despite
all that we'll talk about today one of
the take home points
early on is that zero that is
zero nih grants have
funded psychedelic assisted therapy
clinical trials to the date of the
recording of this webinar
so
let's move through some of the history
of pharmacology so in the late 1930s
albert hoffman was synthesizing a bunch
of compounds he was actually looking at
a drug for women's health related to
blush blood pressure and things like
that
and when they sent lsd 25 or simply lsd
through animal studies and screening
it was apparently useless it was not of
interest but for some reason he was
obsessed with it and then accidentally
exposed himself to it and went on a
famous bicycle ride
since then
by the 1960s for example during the
first sort of renaissance of
psychedelics there were over 40 000
individuals that took part in research
studies not researchers
participants in clinical
studies
so
then
the chapter closed on that there were a
couple of outwardly facing media people
who gave psychedelics a bad name there
was a backlash prohibition of research
and i don't really like to give those
people those things too much credibility
because of all the hard work
and just meticulous nature of the
research space
from the 1940s to the 1960s than helping
us understand more about human
consciousness and the potential of
therapy and there are even books
published in the 1960s about using
psychedelics like lsd for the treatment
of alcoholism
fast forward to more recent times
2004 the university of california ucla
specifically researchers began clinical
trials on psilocybin for treatment
related to things like pain anxiety and
depression in patients with advanced
stage cancer
this is probably considered by some to
be just another
renaissance
we are considered to be
still in that same psychedelics
renaissance and as that potential rises
a lot of myth and misconceptions have
rise to to meet it and we'll get to that
in a second
so much like ucla it's good enough for
california it's good enough for the west
coast it's good enough for the east
coast
john hopkins also started a center for
psychedelic unconscious research in 2006
which has published over 80 articles on
psychedelic research
today we're probably looking at
about
27 000 research articles published on
psychedelic drugs so it's over a
thousand
specifically on psilocybin which comes
from mushrooms and again psilocybin is
the most well studied
psychedelic product
so pharmaceutical interest has also
increased into it's not just
and energy it's not just
quiet nerds doing harmless research that
no one cares about
compass pathways for example is
received
fda status approval status for
breakthrough therapy for psilocybin
treatment that they developed for
treatment resistant depression the usa
also approved a ketamine analog and i
don't want a bunch of angry emails about
how ketamine is not really a psychedelic
but i think it's important
for the story here again this is by
johnson johnson for use in patients
suffering from treatment resisted
depression
2019 usona institute also received us
fda
breakthrough therapy status for a
psilocybin treatment for major
depressive disorder
you know so i think i'd like to just
take a moment to thank the fda for their
working with psychedelic companies
private companies looking to push this
further
if we look at the way
cannabis is rolled out in the united
states we have to wonder
i wonder
what the cannabis space would look like
if companies were allowed to do research
first or engaged in research first
before rolling out products
but again between 2015 and 2020 there
actually have been nearly 550 grants
awarded to researchers engaged engaged
in psychedelic research that's animal
research receptor research observational
research but again
zero zero grants for psychedelic
assisted therapy clinical trials that is
someone's taking a psychedelic they're
sitting in a room
with a clinician and they're measuring
outcomes
and again you can read about that in a
recent publication for 2022 referenced
in the bottom of the slide
so psilocybin much like other drugs
when you consume it it is synthesis it
is metabolized by the body it is
metabolized into solution it acts upon a
variety of targets but
most importantly five ht2a receptors
because the the majority of the effects
of psilocybin are in an lsd for that
matter are prevented if you block the
5ht28 receptor
you know if you have a moment right
5ht2a on your forehead so when you look
in the mirror you can remember this
important receptor
a cannabis compound cannabidiol very
popular these days cbd interacts with 5
ht
1a receptors
and i want to stress 5 hd 2a because
because what a difference a subclass of
receptors can make from
you know your experience with that
substance
but despite the effects of psilocybin
and in popular culture
it is reported to have the most
favorable
safety profile of all psychedelic drugs
the registry of toxic effects of
chemical substances has assigned
psilocybin with a therapeutic index of
641. now this is associated with a
better safety profile
again nicotine has 21 not a great
therapeutic
index
uh
aspirin 199 not a great therapeutic
index so objectively toxicologically
psilocybin has a great therapeutic uh
index a great window
of which to um
to to use it for treatment it's probably
why we see treatment centers already
operating in the united states and these
are legitimate treatment centers where
people get a purified standardized
product this is not you know you're not
going to back alley or the back room at
a discotheque to like get some
psychedelic treatment or to someone's
living room these are in clinical
centers
so
no discussion of psychedelics would
be complete without discussing the
poster problem child of psychedelics lsd
and and things have come a long way in
the way we do research on psychedelics
one of my colleagues
you know uses virtual reality to see how
these drugs fit in receptors and so what
you're seeing in the background here is
actually
in purple lsd
and then those beautiful red ribbons are
actually the protein structure of the
5ht2a receptor so lsd or lysergic acid
diethylamide
or lsd-25
you may have heard i found this out
recently you know when people talk about
oh brown acid or weird acid it's usually
because it's a mixture of other forms of
it lsd 25
is the product we are for the purposes
of our conversation today that we're
talking about but if you go out into the
illicit market
you know backyard chemists are probably
not creating a stable purified form of
this target compound it's probably
present but it's probably present with a
lot of other forms of lsd
so this is again similar to psilocybin a
5ht2a
agonist a drug that targets the 5ht to
t2a receptor and of course these drugs
are promiscuous
they bind other receptor subclasses
except for the 5-ht3 and the 5-hd4
receptor
where are these receptors good question
they're throughout the central nervous
system so your brain your spine widely
expressed in the cortex uh if you rub
the side of your head you can
you can just stick your fingers in
through your skull a little bit you'd be
massaging your cortex which is sort of
a very
evolutionary advanced part of the brain
so the last
brain update that we have received as
living organisms
and it's difficult to study psychedelics
in other organisms because they don't
they barely have a cortex mice rats they
they barely have a cortex and
researchers
measure hallucination or psychedelic
experiences by looking at how many times
their head twitches
so again in a lot of areas of the brain
involving processing of information
we find these five hd two-way receptors
so
there's been a huge
trajectory over decades looking at
various psychedelics um their impact on
humans or impact on cells or impact on
animals and in
the last decade
or so there's been a huge increase
psychedelic
psychedelics take flight as it has been
pointed out by nature magazine here we
see
in gray psilocybin in the orangish
reddish color mdma and in blue lsd we
can start to see that wow there have
been a lot of clinical studies 17 alone
in 2020
slightly less in 2021 the stats aren't
out for 2022 yet because we're still
living it
but i think it was really interesting to
see that
there's been a huge increase in the
publication of clinical studies
particularly on psilocybin as well as
mdma and a little bit of lsd
now psychedelics
can be a very intense
experience for some people
there are bad experiences and and
sometimes these bad trips as they're
called
it is actually currently being discussed
there are there are a large body of
researchers who think that bad trips
actually have a huge therapeutic
relevancy and it's all about how you
integrate these these experiences and i
love this meme on the left because it it
constantly reminds me that again
psychedelics experiences aren't
necessarily tranquil tranquil or
peaceful especially for people working
through trauma or other issues but they
do have
a role
potentially in improving people's lives
so what are some of the abuse liability
or risks of psychedelics well one
there seems to be some harm that can be
caused in people with psychedelics or
predisposition
to
psychosis
again don't take my work for it matthew
johnson uh william richards who trained
me on sulciman assisted therapy as well
as roland griffith have published
studies looking at
guidelines for safety and the abuse
potential of these products
you know fear panic confusion and
potentially dangerous behavior
are other issues i've talked to
clinicians who have administered this
therapy and you know now they
now they have you know some facilities
have changed their protocols because if
they you leave doors unlocked and
someone gets a confused or panic episode
even if it's just last two or three
minutes they might get up and run out
the door and so definitely that has
happened in clinical settings
there can be moderate elevations and
pulse and blood pressure there can be
headaches in the following days
there can also be
what's called persisting perceptual
changes or
persisting perception disorder ppd which
is the fancy term for flashbacks
where people are experiencing
changes
and
maybe unwanted experiences
after being exposed to the substance
however the good news is is data and
you know real world evidence suggests
no
no addiction potential really for these
substances that is
no one's jonesen for lsd or psilocybin
the way
that maybe you might observe it for
opioids or caffeine or other substances
again if you're interested in this area
i would highly recommend starting with
the 2008 publication human hallucinogen
research guidelines for safety it's
absolutely fascinating
so if you were to just base everything
you know about psychedelics on the media
you would think that lsd perhaps is the
most widely studied well-known thing and
the thing that everyone's using the
thing we only know about
just like this cover of time life or
sorry cover of life magazine from
uh i think 1966 the exploding threat of
the mind drug that got out of control
um
and um and so you know llc tends to get
a lot of notoriety but
for our first myth we're going to bust
today
psychedelics are more than lsd and
mushrooms
what do i mean by that well there is a
fish out here that people can consume
out in the ocean um this can cause
something called i think it's called
shark sickness um and and again people
have used this for a long time
for different ailments there's also
variety like arthritis and pain and
things like that uh but it can also you
know with
overindulgence can lead to people being
kind of comatose for a couple days or um
you know it's a very fascinating thing
um there's also corals and other sea
life that produce uh tryptamines and
other things that are of interest
um
there are also amphibians
um certain types of octopi uh even
horseshoe crabs all produce um some
compounds notably is the
tetrodotoxin which again
is
one hand is it turns can turn people
into zombies is associated with that
effect that some of you may be familiar
with watching this but it's also been
used a long time to treat things like
arthritis and pain and other conditions
so invertebrates vertebrates ants fish
and amphibians
you can find marine tryptamines
hallucinogenic fish psychedelic
amphibians i don't mean i didn't mention
insects today
um
just because i didn't have room on the
slide but these all have potential for
human consumption
and or abuse i'm not i hesitated to
share this information with folks i
don't want you all running out to just
start eating things out of the ocean and
hope of having a good time i would
really strongly strongly suggest you
look up this orcillini article from 2018
about psychedelic fauna to really get a
sense of the risks associated with some
of these products but again
the wide
wide breadth of living psychedelic
organisms
that swim in our oceans and hop along in
our fields
so
what about these companies we're all
hearing about you can go on a
any
you know
tracker for stock psilocybin alpha is a
great resource this is where this image
was pulled there are a lot of publicly
traded companies that don't sell
psychedelics most of them don't i think
all of them do not sell psychedelics so
what are they doing exactly they're
doing research this is not a gimmick
this is not a ploy
this is a real thing and anyone can join
in the fun
you know you can
you can start a company apply for
research permissions if needed maybe
you're just doing a survey may not need
permission from the fda to just
survey people about their perceptions
you could do a literature review you
could engage in some way remember john
hopkins
center for psychedelic studies has
published like 80 reviews
of the literature on the subject
raising funds is great because you can
pay for more advanced research animal
research cell research receptor research
human research
you can conduct for example maps with
their ptsd study with mdmas and phase
three currently very exciting that is
the technical term for that that is very
exciting the soda
for major depressive disorders they're
looking at psilocybin in a phase two
study
also exciting
um so again when we think about these
companies they're not selling mushrooms
they're not selling tabs of acid
they are engaged in research in a very
high level with federal
permission so the next subject i want to
talk about is
psychedelic gimmick ventures and i think
um you know if you want to this has been
a this is an art that as old as humanity
itself you can picture a guy in a top
head at the back of a caboose like
saying i've got the cure-all for
everything
um but there's this quote by alan watts
that i like to go to when i'm trying to
think about the sort of the principle
of this this misconception of this myth
and it's the quote is anybody who tells
you that he has some way of leading you
to spiritual enlightenment is like
somebody who picks your pocket and sells
you your own watch
i always like that
quote and coming back to it when i'm
examining and looking at
new offerings
in this space
so
a couple questions to ask yourself when
you're looking at some of these wellness
retreats who is overseeing it are they
qualified in any way other than just
being really good at taking psychedelics
there's a lot of issues around abuse
of all types around people who go to
unlicensed
backyard shamans
for
a psychedelic lawless therapy
there there are people who are in the
business of conjuring up historical
narratives about these products um now
while it's true that many many
indigenous populations may have
cultivated or created an environment
where these things could thrive not all
of them
uh use it and i think the sonoran desert
toad the dmt frog as some people call it
but it's actually a toad
um there's no historical indigenous use
there we're
we're literally living in a time where
we're discovering
new creatures that have this ability
this potential that have evolved
and what's happening unfortunately in
this day and age
is
that
these
these these
toads are being brutally harvested
people say they milk them
people say you know to discuss
they're actually skinned alive
and the their their medicine their
extract their milk is brutally extracted
and their
environment has been decimated by
illicit market influences
so um it's great that you all want to
pursue enlightenment
but it's you have to make sure it's not
the cost of decimating the wildlife
populations and
would be really amazing if these toads
and other amphibians and fish and corals
and mushrooms could continue
to evolve
continue on their trajectory
and not be licked out of existence
the the populations of sonoran endears
the toad are considered threatened or
endangered so
the psychedelic toad could end
with our generation so one of the myths
i hear about all the time
is about how psychedelics makes you a
better or more peaceful person but again
it's
you know practice is the past the path
to mastery if you take psychedelics
you'll probably just get really good at
taking psychedelics unless you're
already good at something and so
i want to illustrate this point so
vikings were known for taking henbane
and omni and muscaria to give them
unearthly powers and here's a quote i
feel unstoppable now the gods of war
have reawakened me they've ignited my
ego and want me to go to war again
oh wait wait wait
a viking didn't say that hundreds of
years ago
uh that was actually mike tyson just a
little while ago
after consuming dmt
um possibly along with cannabis and
returning to fighting at the age of 54.
i don't know if it really brought him
peace when he's talking about becoming a
god of war and want to become the oldest
heavyweight champion in history
so taking psychedelics doesn't make you
a better or more peaceful person just
from taking them
you know we can leave the viking
berserkers before they'd go off and raid
a village and do ungodly things with
godly powers from psychedelics
you know they would consume
these things mike tyson think about him
he's 54 55 56 now
going back into boxing after consuming
psychedelics trauma
ego death
often associated revisiting trauma and
ego often associated with psychedelics
isn't always a tranquil experience for
the participant and the scientific
literature is filled with examples of
hallucinogenic experience
that are not innately peaceful
i'd also like to point out that
oppressive and racist groups are
associated with perpetually
overindulging in psychedelics giving an
example some of the people involved in
the january 6 rise or they went in to go
kill elected officials and do the whole
overthrow of the country
some of them reported to be on
psychedelics including the guy wearing
horns um and there were even people with
exposed tattoos for dark websites where
people purchase and consume psychedelics
you can read more about this in vice
magazine
so
in summary i just want to give you a few
gems to help you
navigate
this really interesting and fascinating
space
first of all
not much of this is new there's a rich
history of scientific discovery going
back
about a hundred years
um
largely the reason we can experience
these effects are because of
serotonergic receptors
or the 5-ht 2a receptor
psychedelics are much more than lsd and
mushroom there is a whole ocean of
psychedelics out there in the form of
marine life to be explored and harnessed
for the benefit
of humans
public companies don't sell psychedelics
they are in the business of research and
developing approved products in clinical
use
um if you're going to go to a
psychedelic wellness retreat or
something like that trust only train
professionals with your health
and be environmentally conscious
don't achieve enlightenment at the
expense of destroying the environment or
driving
sonoran desert toads or ayahuasca vines
to the point of extinction
again psychedelics and even in according
to clinical studies will not turn you
into a peacenik or change your religion
so if you've enjoyed some of the artwork
and stuff most of it is mine the nature
picks but some of this other stuff is
from my podcast how to launch an
industry where me and my colleagues get
together to discuss
clinical studies and other research um
here we have dr nick aurora dr deb
kimlis dr ethan russo dr sarah jane
warren myself dr marku and
uh
who we call gmp dave dave and valencia
who runs the gmp collective and inspects
facilities for compliance to different
standards so if you've liked any of this
i encourage you to shoot me an email or
check out
our podcast wherever
you download those sorts of things thank
you so much
you